okay hello everybody
we'll get started
um
so
just recapping what we did
[Music]
a
in the last lecture on tuesday
we um
had a
it was kind of a two is the second part
of a two lecture sequence on the
hierarchy theorem
higher hierarchy theorems for time and
space
and using the hierarchy theorems to show
that there are that there is a problem
which is
intractable that's provably outside of
polynomial time
and that was this equivalence problem
for regular expressions with
exponentiation
and then we had a short discussion
about oracles
and the possibility that similar methods
might you might be used to show that
satisfiability is outside of p which
would then of course solve the p versus
mp problem and argued that um
it seems unlikely
um this kind of a meta theorem not not a
well uh
well-defined notion
but seems unlikely that the methods that
were used for proving
the um
uh
the intractability of um
equivalence of regular expressions with
exponentiation could be used to solve p
versus np at least um the the
diagonalization method kind of in a pure
form whatever that means uh that's not
going to be um enough
so today we're going to
shift gears again begin a somewhat
different topic which is really kind of
um going to be our uh
again a
few lectures on probabilistic
computation which is going to wrap round
out the semester for us
um and we're going to start by talking
about a different model of computation
which allows for uh probabilis
probabilism in the
measuring the amount of probabilism or
measuring the probability allowing for
probabilism in the computation
define an associated complexity class uh
this class bpp
and then start to start the discussion
of an example um
about something called branching
programs
okay um
so uh with that in mind um
uh
um
a
uh
so we're gonna start off by defining
the notion of a probabilistic
turing machine or ptm
um a probabilistic turing machine is a
lot like
the way we have thought about
non-deterministic touring machines
in that it's a kind of a machine that
can have multiple choices multiple ways
to go
in its computation so there's not just
going to be a fixed uh deterministic
path
um of its computation but there's going
to be a tree of possibilities um and for
our purposes we're going to limit the
branching in that tree to be either
um a step of the computation where
there's no branching where it's a
deterministic step
uh as shown over here um so every step
of the way leads uniquely to the next
step
or there might be some steps which have
a choice and we're only going to allow
for these purposes uh to keep life
simple
um having only uh a choice among two
possibilities
um
and we'll associate to that
uh
um
the notion of a
probability that each choice will have a
50 50 chance of getting taken
and this kind of corresponds with the
way some of us or some of you think
about non-determinism which is not
exactly right up and up until this point
is that the machine is kind of taking a
random branch it really we don't think
about it randomly until now now we're
going to think about the machine as
actually taking
sort of picking a random choice among
all the different branches that it could
make um and picking the choice kind of
uniformly by flipping a coin every time
it has an option of which way to go
uh
now you could
define i'm getting a question here uh
the uh a machine that has several
different ways to more than two ways to
go and then you would need to have a
three-way coin a four-way coin and so on
and you could define it all of that that
way
as well but it doesn't end up giving you
anything different or anything uh
interesting or new for uh for the kinds
of things we're going to be discussing
so and it's just going to be simpler to
keep the discussion limited to the case
where the machine can only have two
possibilities um if it's going to be
having a choice at all or or just one
possibility when there's no choice
okay so um so now we're going to have to
talk about the probability of a
the machine taking a sum branch of its
computation so you imagine here here is
the same computation tree that we've
seen before in the case of ordinary
non-deterministic machines where you
have m on w there could be several
different ways to go and there might be
some particular branch but now we want
to talk about the probability that the
machine actually ends up picking that
branch
and it's going to be
um
uh
you know when we talk about
the machine having a choice of ways to
go we're going to associate that with a
coin flip so we're going to call that a
coin flip step when the machine has a
possibility of ways to go and so on a
particular branch
the probability of that branch occurring
is going to be one over two to the
number of coin flips
coin flip states on that branch
and the reason for i mean this is kind
of the the
the definition that makes sense um in
that if you imagine looking at the
computation tree here and here is the
branch that we're focusing on um of
interest
every time there's a coin flip on that
branch
there's a 50 50 chance of taking a
different branch or staying on that
branch
so the more coin flips there are on some
particular branch the less likely that
branch would be the one that the machine
actually actually ends up taking taking
and so it's going to be one over two to
the number of coin flips
and that's the way we're defining it
now once we have that notion
we can also talk about the probability
that the machine ends up accepting
because each as before each of these
branches is going to end up
at an accept state or reject state i'm
thinking about this only in terms of
deciders
and
the probability of
the machine accepting here is just going
to be the sum over all probabilities of
the branches that end up accepting
so just add up all of those
probabilities of a branch leading to an
accept and we'll call that the
probability that the machine accepts its
input
[Music]
and the probability that the machine
rejects is going to be one minus the
probability that it accepts
because it's going to the machine um on
every branch is either either going to
do one or the other
okay um
now if you're thinking about a
particular language
that the machine is trying to decide
this probabilistic machine now is trying
to decide
um you know
on on each input
some of the branches of the machine may
not may give the correct answer they're
going to accept when the input is in the
language other branches may give the
wrong answer they may reject when the
input is in the language and vice versa
so there's going to be a possibility of
error now in the machine in any
particular branch it might actually give
the wrong answer
and what we're going to say is bound
that error
over all possible inputs
um and so and uh
we'll say that the machine for any
epsilon greater than or equal to zero
um we will say that the machine decides
the language with error probability
epsilon
if that's the worst that can possibly
happen you know if every
um for every input the machine gives the
wrong answer
with probability at most epsilon
um equivalently if you like to spell it
out a little bit more
you know
a little differently
for
strings that are in the language the
probability that the machine rejects
that input is going to be at most
epsilon and for strings in the language
the probability of for strings not in
the language the probability that
accepts is a most epsilon
so again this is
the machine doing the the thing that
it's not supposed to be doing for things
in the language it should be rejecting
very rarely for things not in the
language it should be accepting very
rarely and that's what this bound is
doing for you
okay
um
[Music]
so let's just see uh
so we'll talk about so i'm getting some
questions here about um
um
so let me just look at these one second
here
the
yeah so
probability zero so there's a
possibility that the machine have might
have a probability zero say of accepting
that means there are no branches that
end up accepting or probability zero of
rejecting there were no rejecting
branches
um but i think we're going to talk in a
minute about the connection between this
and and the standard notion of np
um so just hold off on that for a second
uh
also about what what about the you know
the um the possibility that the machine
is you know
being a decider or running in a certain
amount of time um so we will look at
time-bounded machines
in a second um
on the next slide or two um talking
about machines that run in polynomial
time so that means all branches have to
halt within some polynomial number of
steps um so that's where we're going
but for the time being we're only
looking at the siders where the machine
has to hold on every branch
but some branches might run for a long
time but
for now we're not going to be thinking
about machines that have branches that
run um forever where all of our machines
are deciders so they they hold on every
branch
see there's anything else here no so why
don't i move on so let's define now
the class bpp
using this notion of a probabilistic
turing machine which is now going to be
running in polynomial time
so bpp is going to be another one of
these complexity classes a collection of
languages like p and np and p space and
so on and um but it's going to be now
associated with the capabilities of
these probabilistic machines the kinds
of languages that they can do
so we'll say the class bpp
is the set of languages a
such that there's some probabilistic
polynomial time
during machines so all branches have to
halt within you know to the k for some k
so some polynomial time
polynomial time probabilistic turing
machine decides a with error possibility
at most one-third
so in other words
when it's accepting
for some for strings in the language the
machine has to reject with at most
one-third so saying it equivalently for
strings in the language it has to accept
with two-thirds probability and for
strings not in the language it has to
reject what two-thirds probability at
least
in both cases
um
okay
somehow ended up with
didn't check my animation here but okay
that's fine so there is a um
uh
now if you look at the one-third here in
the definition
uh
you know it seems strange to define a
complexity class in terms of some
arbitrary constant like one-third why
didn't we use one-quarter
you know or uh
you know one-tenth in the definition of
bpp
and say the machine has to get have an
error with at most one tenth or one
hundredth uh
well it doesn't matter
and that's the point of this uh
next statement called the amplification
lemma
which says that
um
you can always if you have a machine
that's running in a certain
uh
a polynomial time that's running within
this with a certain error which it is
most one-half if you have an error
one-half it's not interesting because
the machine
could just flip a coin for every uh
input and it could get uh the right
answer with it with probability one-half
so probability one-half is not
interesting you have to have probability
strictly less than one-half for the
machine to actually be doing something
that's meaningful about that language
so
um
if you have a
probabilistic turing machine that has
error
let's say epsilon one which is at most
one half which is less than one half
then you can convert that to any
error probability you want
for some other
polynomial time probabilistic turing
machine so you can make that error which
maybe starts out as one-third and you
can drive that error down to one out of
one over or google
um
and seriously you can really make the
error extremely extremely small
using a very simple procedure
and and that's simply this
so if you're starting out with a machine
that has an error possibility of
one-third say so that means
two-thirds of the time it's going to get
the right answer and at most one-third
of the time at least two-thirds of the
time the right answer most one-third of
the time the the incorrect answer
whether that's accepting or rejecting
um and now you want to get that answer
down to be something much that error
down to something much smaller
um
the the idea is you just you're going to
take that machine
and you're
going to run it multiple times
it's kind of with independent runs if
that me if you want to think about it
you sort of more formally speaking but
it's sort of intuitive you're just going
to run the machine
uh tossing your coins
um
uh instead of just running it once
you're going to run the machine 100
times or or a million times but you can
do that so it's a constant factor
and even a thousand times is going to be
enough to increase your confidence in
the result tremendously because
if you run the machine a thousand times
and 600 of those times the mach the
machine accepts and 400 of the time the
machine rejects
um
uh
it's very powerful evidence that this
machine is biased toward accepting that
it's accepting most of the time
um so it's um was
uh
if it had an error
probability of most one-third um
uh
the the probability that you're
seeing it except
600 times when really two-thirds of the
time it's rejecting overall
is extremely unlikely
um and you can calculate that uh which
we're not going to bother to do but it's
a routine probability calculation uh to
show that the the probability that if
you run it a whole bunch of times and
you see the majority coming up
um which is not the
not the right answer that's extremely
the
the probability of that is extremely
small
um
so i'm not saying that very clearly but
the the the
the method here is you're going to
take your original machine
which has error probability one-third
or whatever it whatever it is some you
know you know maybe
has error probability 49
and you run it uh for a large number of
times and then you take the majority
vote
and
it you're kind of sampling the the
outcomes of this machine and if you take
enough samples it's overwhelmingly
likely since you're just doing them
uniformly you're taking those samples
uniformly it's overwhelmingly likely
that you're going to be seeing the
predominant one come up more often um
and exactly what that right value is
we're not going to bother to calculate
but that's something that
you know if you i will i'll refer you to
the textbook or you know that's the kind
of thing that comes up in any elementary
probability book and it's sort of very
intuitive so i don't want to spend the
time and do that calculation which is
not all that interesting
um
uh okay so just one quick question here
that i'm getting
what happens if you bound if the error
is greater than a half i don't think
that because we're bounding the error so
we're not saying the error actually is
one you know like sixty percent on
everything because then if you knew the
error was sixty percent
guaranteed you can always just flip the
flip your answer around and get your um
error to be 40
but you know i'm saying the error is
that most
whatever epsilon is and so um if it's
you're saying the error is at most 60
percent it doesn't tell you anything
um
okay um
[Music]
uh
another question is does the
amplification lemma also justify that
the choice of model with binary
branching choices is equivalent to any
other
perhaps you could say that um
because you can change those
you know if you had through a three-way
branching um you can simulate that with
two-way branching to any accuracy that
you want um
you know
not going to get it down to zero but
you're going to get it very close
um so it's
maybe it's the amplification level maybe
it's
yeah sort of all related um
okay let's move on um
so
the way that it's helpful to think about
this class let's let's contrast it with
the other model of non-deterministic
computation that we have is
non-determinism is np
uh so non-deterministic then the model
of non-deterministic polynomial time
computation was np um the other class
and um
so the way
it's i think one way to look at to think
about non-determinism in the case of np
is
for strings in the language for your np
turing machine
there's at least one accepting branch
so i'm indicating the accepting ones in
green and the non-accepting one the
rejecting branches in red
so you could have
almost all of the branches be rejecting
branches um
for strings in the language as long as
there is at least one accepting branch
that's just the way non-determinism
works the accepting branch overrules all
the all of the others it's only when
you're not in the language that you that
all of the branches turn out to have to
be rejecting that's when the rejecting
sort of
you know it's it has no accepting branch
to overroll it
um but the situation for bpp is a little
different it is is different um there
it's kind of majority majority rules
so um
in the case for strings in the language
you you need to have
a large or you know the the overwhelming
majority of the
branches have to be accepting and for
strings not in the language the
overwhelming majority have to be
rejecting
what you're not going to allow in the
case of
bpp is kind of you know
an in-between
uh
state where it's sort of 50-50
um or very very close to 50-50 um those
kinds of machines are not
don't qualify as
uh deciding a language in bpp they
always have to kind of lean one way or
lean the other way for every input
otherwise you won't be able to do the
amplification so need to have some bias
um away from in half in
in accepting or rejecting
um
so
let me so i was going to ask a check-in
i think at this point yes let's
so just thinking about bpp i hope i was
clear so if there's questions about that
i think i've
somehow didn't
i'm not sure i described it totally well
here um so i'm going to ask a few
questions about ppp but if you have any
questions for me first
go ahead
um
okay why don't we just run the check-in
let me launch this and then i can answer
questions as you're asking
did i start that yeah
okay so you have to um
check all of these that you think are
true
um
can you think of non-deterministic
turing machines as try all branches at
once
and get the right answer
um
and bp is guess only one or uh i guess
only one branch i don't know um
you know i would say a little
differently i would say i i would think
of non-determinism as you can still just
try one branch but you always guess the
right one
um
so there's some sort of a you know
magical power that allows you always to
guess the right answer if there's a
right guess uh if you're in the language
uh in the case of bpp
you're going to be um picking a random
branch no matter what
and you know that the random branch is
likely to give the right answer but not
guaranteed
and the implication the amplification
limit tells you you can arrange things
so that it's extremely likely
that the random branch is going to give
you the right answer
okay let's see how we doing on our uh
check-in here
um
got a lot of vote we've got a lot of
support for all candidates
um
and um
i'll give you give you another uh
a little bit of time here because
there's a bunch of questions almost like
four check-ins at once
um
but we have two more check real
check-ins coming
later um
okay so why don't we uh come and
let's uh give another 10 seconds and
then i'm going to stop
closing down
one two three
close
okay
so uh we've got a lot of support here uh
and in fact
that's good because all of them are true
um
some of them are easier to see than
others
so first of all c is very easy to see um
because that that's a going to be a
machine that has the correct answer all
of it all of the time so that's error
probability zero
um on both accepting and rejecting
um
this is a little harder d is a little
bit harder to see that's in p space but
you know you could
calculate for every branch
um what its probability is and you can
just go through all the branches and add
up all those probabilities in a p-space
machine
so um you have to think about a little
bit but d is not too hard to see either
closure under complement
if you just take your
your bpp machine and you flip the answer
on every branch
um that's typically doesn't work in
non-determined ordinary non-determinism
but it does work here
because it's going to change a bias
toward accepting into a bias toward
rejecting and vice versa so bpp is
closed under compliment
uh and closure under union it kind of
follows from the amplification level as
long as you can make the probability
extremely small
then you can just run the two different
machines
and
even though the they each might make a
mistake cumulatively the total
the probability that each one of them
that either of them will make a mistake
is still small and so you can just run
to the two machines and take the or of
the responses that they get and it's
still very likely to give the right
answer for the union
okay um
[Music]
let's continue
uh so what i'm going to do now
for the rest of the lecture uh is and
it's actually going to spill over into
the lecture after thanksgiving because
this is going to introduce an important
method for us
is to look at an example of a problem
that's in bpp
um i love to teach things by using
examples um and so this is a very good
example because it has a lot of meat to
it
and it's a very interesting example in
general proving things in bpp which are
not trivially there because they're
already in p they tend to be uh somewhat
more involved than um
uh some of the other algorithms we've
seen so there are no simple examples of
problems in bpp
which are not already in p
um
so this is uh
one example that we're going to go
through of a problem in bpp that's not
known to bnp
of course things could collapse down um
but uh uh
as star as far as we know
this is
um not this language is not in p so
let's let's see what the language is
has to do with these things called
branching programs the branching program
is a structure that looks like this
so let's understand what the pieces are
first of all it's a graph directed graph
and uh we're not we're not going to
allow and there is are no cycles allowed
in this graph it's a directed acyclic
graph
um
so you can no loops allowed
and
the nodes are in two categories
there are query nodes which are labeled
with a variable letter
and output nodes which are labeled
either zero or one
and lastly there is a one of the query
nodes is going to be or one of the nodes
is going to be designated as a start
okay
and so what you do
is
the way um
this is a model of computation um and
the way we actually use
a branching program
is we
have some assignment to the variables
that's going to be the input
so you take all of the the variables
there are three variables in this case
um x1 x2 and x3 you assign you give them
some truth assignment um so x let's
let's say zeros and one so x1 is zero x1
is one or whatever
and
once you have the truth assignment you
start
at the start variable
and you
and you look at its label
and you see what value the input has
assigned to that variable
so if x1 assigned
a one you're going to follow down the
one branch but assigned to zero you
follow you go down the zero branch and
then when you get down to the
next node
that's another
variable that you're going to have to
query depending upon what the input
assignment is
and you're just going to
continue that process
because there are no cycles
you're going to end up at one of the
output nodes because all of the variable
nodes all the all the query nodes
have
two outgoing edges one labeled zero one
labeled one
so you're gonna eventually end up at an
output node and that's going to be the
output of the branching program
so we'll do let's do a quick example
so if x1 is 1 x2 is 0 and x3 is 1.
so we again we start at the start
variable the start node that has the
indicated with the
arrow coming in from nowhere so you're
going to start at x1
uh
the node labeled x1 so you have to look
and see what is x1 in the input it's a
1. so you're going to follow down the
one branch
now you see the next node oh that's an
x3
see what's x3 in the input x3 is a 1.
so you go down to one branch again
now you have an x2 node take a look at
the input x2 is a zero you follow the
zero branch now you're at an output
branch output node so that's a zero and
that's the output of the of the of this
computation so
um writing it this way and thinking
about it as a boolean function which
maps you know strings of zeros and ones
we have f of one zero one representing
those that assign that assignment that
equals zero that was the output and
uh
that's the output of this computation
okay
um
so important to underst we're going to
spend a lot of time
you know talking about branching
programs so it's critical to understand
this model i think it's fairly simple
but if you didn't get it please ask
we can easily correct up any
misunderstanding at this point
it's not exactly the same as a dfa
dfas for one thing can take inputs of
any length
um
this
this has inputs of some particular
length
where the branching program has some
fixed number of variables
this one has three so this only takes
inputs of length three um so there's
maybe some connection to thinking these
estates and so on but it's a different
model
so now we'll say that two branching
programs
um
okay let me just ask one more question
not all nodes need to be used right
um
yeah
there's no requirement that all nodes
need to be used and that even could be
inaccessible nodes i'm not preventing
that uh that could be okay um so on the
particular branch certainly you're not
gonna you know when you're executing
this
branching program on an input obvious
certainly you're to have a path that's
going to only use some part of the
tree
part of the graph
but
there might be some
paths that can
can never occur
you know so if you went down x equal to
one here and then x three was zero
now you're re-reading x one so you'd
never you could you wouldn't go down
this branch
unless you
i think all of the branches in this
particular branching program could get
used but i didn't check that so maybe
i'm wrong um
okay so let's continue two branching
programs may may or may not compute the
same function
um we'll say they're equivalent if they
do
now
two
branching programs can be equivalent
even though they superficially look
different from one another
and we're interested in the
computational problem of given two of
these branching programs do they compute
the same function do they in other words
do they always give the same answer
um on the setting of the input uh
so we'll define the associated language
equivalence problem for branching
programs says that you're given two of
these branching programs and they're
equivalent to be in the language we're
going to sometimes write equivalence
using the mathematical notation of the
three lined equals equal sign
the equivalence sign
okay that means they compute the same
they always give the same answer
now that problem
turns out to be cohen p
complete i've asked you to show on your
homework i believe
um
this is not a super hard reduction um
it's the in comp complete by the way is
the complement of an mp complete problem
or equivalently it's a problem to which
all co np problems are polynomial time
reducible and it's in coin
[Music]
so
uh
this is coin p complete
and
that's for you to show um
but that has an important
significance for us right now
um because if you if
you know looking at the question of
whether this problem is in bpp
the fact that it's coin
co np complete suggests that the answer
is no
because
if
a co np complete or np complete problem
more in bpp
because everything else in np or cmp is
reducible to that problem then all of
those np or co-np problems would be in
bpp for the exactly the same reason that
we've seen before
um and that's not known to be the case
and not believed to be the case um
so
uh we don't expect that a co-mp complete
problem is going to be in bpp um that
would be you know an amazing uh and
surprising uh
uh result so um
because i i hope i made it clear in my
previous um you know in previous
discussion that
you know the bpp from a practical
standpoint is very close to being like p
um because you can make the error
probability of the machine so incredibly
low
um
that
you know it's a comparable
uh
you know if you run the machine and the
error probability is like one over
google um
then it's sort of
even greater than the probability that
some alpha particle came in and flipped
the value of what some internal uh
memory cell in your in your computation
so if you have an extremely low error
probability it's pretty good from a
practical standpoint um
so it would be amazing if np problems
were solvable in bpp um
so
this is not the language we're going to
use as our example we're going to look
at a related restricted version of this
problem about equivalence for branching
programs and that i'm going to introduce
right now
okay any questions here
don't see any questions
um
fading out
uh okay
um
so let's move on
so we're going to talk about branching
programs that are what are called read
once
read once branching programs
and those are simply branching programs
that are not allowed to re-read
an input that they've previously read
so for example
is this
branching program a read once branching
program
no
this branching program is not a read
once branching program because
um
you can
find a path that's going to cause you to
read the same variable more than once so
it's not going to be a read once
um so over here let's not read once
because there's two
occurrences of an x1 on the same branch
now you might ask why would anybody want
to do that because you've already read
the value of x1 well i mean in the case
of this particular branching program
there might be a value because you could
have got to this x x1 branch by going
this way or that way
um
but that's a separate question
if we restrict our attention
to read once branching programs then the
problem of testing equivalence becomes
uh
very different in character
and in fact we're going to give a
probabilistic algorithm uh
a bpp algorithm to solve that problem
so the equivalence problem for read once
branching programs which are not allowed
to re-read variables on any path
um that's interestingly going to be
solvable with a probabilistic
uh polynomial time algorithm you know
with a small error probability
um
so i'm going to run a check in now but
let's make sure we're all together on
this so i got a good question here can
every boolean function be described by a
branching program yes
that's an easy exercise but you can make
branch branching programs are um they
may be large
uh you can describe any boolean function
with some branching program
that's not hard to show
um
other questions are we all together on
understanding what read once means and
branching programs and all that stuff
this is a good time to ask if you're not
um
okay so let's do the check-in
so
as i pointed out we will show that the
equivalence for read once branching
programs is solvable in bpp
can we use that to solve the general
case for branching programs
by converting branch general branching
programs to read once branching programs
and then run running the read once test
so
what do you think
okay i'm seeing a lot of uh
correct answers here um so let's let's
wrap this one one up quickly
um
another 10 seconds please
okay
ready are we all ready
one two three closing
all right yes
most of you have
uh
answered correctly um
well answer a is not a very good answer
because we already commented on the
previous slide that we don't know how to
do
the general case in bpp so it would be
kind of surprising if right here i'm
saying yes we could do it
by using the restricted case so
you know i think a
better answer would be to one of the
no's but
as i did comment you can always convert
you can always do any uh boolean
function uh with a
well maybe i didn't say it for read once
branching programs but you even read
once branching programs can do any
compute any boolean function um so the
the conversion is possible but in
general will not be polynomial time and
you can if you imagine you've been
trying to do the conversion over here
you could convert this branching program
to read once um but you'd have to
basically separate the two
uh
um
you know instead of re-reading the x1
you could remember that x1 value but
then you would not be you couldn't
reconverge over here you'd have to keep
those two those two
threads of the those two branches of the
computation apart
those two paths apart from one another
and already the branching program would
start to increase in size by doing that
um
and um
so in general
conversion converting is possible but it
requires a big expansion a big
increase in the size
and then we will
not allow a polynomial time algorithm
anymore even in probabilistic in the
probabilistic case
um
okay um
so now let's start to look at the
possibility of showing that this
equivalence problem is solvable in bpp
and it's going to take us in kind of
a strange direction but let's let's try
to get our intuition going first by
doing something
which seems like the most obvious
obvious approach
um
so here
uh so we're gonna
give a
an algorithm now um
uh which is going to be an attempt
it's not going to work but nevertheless
it's going to have the germ of the right
idea or the or the
not the germ but the beginning of the
right way to think about it
so here are the two branching read once
branching programs are b1 and b2
and i want to see
do they compute the same function or not
um so one thing you might try
is just running them on a bunch of
randomly selected
assignments or inputs
all right so you're going to you can
just um
take two randomness input assignments
just take x1
flip a coin to say it's one of zero x do
the same for x two and so on
um then you get some input assignment
you run the two branching programs on
that assignment
and maybe that doesn't give you know
even if they agree it doesn't give you a
lot of confidence that you got the right
answer uh
that they're really equivalent so you do
it a hundred times whatever some some
number of times um
and
of course
if
they uh ever disagree
on some assignment on one of those
assignments then you know they're not
equivalent and you can immediately
reject
um
but
uh what i'd like to say is if they
agree
on those
you know hundred
tries those hundred assignments there
then
there then they are um
uh
at least i'll i haven't found a place
where they disagree so i'm gonna say
that they're equivalent
is that a reasonable thing uh to do
well it might be
uh it depends on k um
so the critical thing is what value of k
should you pick
which is going to be big enough to allow
us to draw the conclusion that if you
run it for k times and you never see a
difference
then you can
conclude
with good confidence that the two
branching programs are equivalent
because
you've tried to look for
a difference and you never found one
well the thing is is that
um
k is going to have to be pretty big
uh
so
looking at it this way if the two
branching programs were equivalent
then certainly they're always going to
give the same value
um
so the probability that the machine
accepts is going to be one and that's
good
because we want for
this is a case when we're in the
language we want the probability of
acceptance to be high and here the
probability of acceptance is actually
one
so it's always going to accept when the
two uh branching
programs were equivalent
but what happens when the branching
programs are not equivalent
now we want the probability of rejection
to be high the probability of acceptance
should be very low
um
right so if if they're not equivalent we
want the probability that the machine
rejects is going to be
high if they're not equivalent because
that that's what the correct answer is
well the only way the machine is going
to reject
if it finds
um a place
where the two branching programs
disagree
but but
those two branching programs even though
not equivalent
might disagree rarely
they might only disagree on one input
assignment out of the two to the end
possibilities
so these two inequivalent branching
programs might agree almost everywhere
just except at one place and then that's
enough for them not to be equivalent but
the problem is that if you're just going
to do random sampling
um the likelihood of finding that one
exceptional place where the two disagree
is very low you're going to have to do
an enormous number of samples before
you're likely to actually to to to find
that uh that point of difference um and
so
um
in order to be confident that you're
going to find that difference if there
is one you're going to have to do
exponentially many samples and you don't
have time to do that with a polynomial
time algorithm
um
you're just going to have to flip too
many coins you have to run too many
different
samples
different assignments through these two
machines
and um because they're almost
they're different but they're almost the
same
um
so we're going to need to find a
different method
and
um the the idea is we're going to run
these two
branching programs
in some crazy way
instead of running them on zeros and
ones that we've been we've been doing it
so far we're going to feed in
values for the variables
which are non-boolean
they are going to be going to set x1 to
2 x3 to 7
x
4 to 15.
of course that doesn't seem to make any
sense but it's nevertheless going to
turn out to be useful a useful thing to
do and it's going to give us some
insight into
the equivalence or equivalence of these
branching programs um
okay um
so let's just i think are we at the end
yeah we're at the break here so why
don't i i'm getting some questions
coming in which is great um i will
answer those questions but why don't i
start off our uh
break and then um
okay
okay so
there's a question about whether these
this machine runs deterministically or
not so which machine are we talking
about
so the branching programs themselves
that they'd run deterministically you
give them an assignment to the um to the
input variables
that's going to determine a path through
each branching program
which is eventually going to output a
zero or a one
and you want to know do those two
branching programs always give the same
value no matter what the input was
but the branching programs themselves
were deterministic
um now the machine that's trying to
make the determination of whether those
two branching programs are equivalent
that machine that we're going to be
arguing is going to be a probabilistic
machine so it's a kind of
non-deterministic machine that's going
to have different possible ways to go
depending upon the outcome if it's of
its coin tosses
so it you can think of as
non-determinist you know
non-determinism in the ordinary sense
about how like that it has a tree of
possibilities
but um now
you know the way we're thinking about
acceptance is different you know that
instead of accepting if there's just one
uh accept branch
the machine for it to accept um has to
have a majority of the branches be
accepting um
and uh
you know
so it's it's
there's some similarities but some
differences with the usual way we think
of non-determinism
so what's the motivation behind
introducing this type of turing machine
well i mean there's a lot
i guess there are two motivations
uh
probabilistic algorithms sometimes
called monte carlo algorithms um
uh turn out to be useful in practice for
a variety of things
and um
so that led to
um
people to think about them in the
context of complexity
um they're related in some ways to
quantum computers which are also
probabilistic in in a somewhat different
way um but they also have a very nice um
uh
um
formulation in complexity theory
so complexity theorists like to think
about probabilistic computation because
i mean you can do interesting things
with probabilistic machines and the
complexity classes associated are also
interesting so as you'll see
it leads us in an interesting direction
uh to consider how to solve this problem
this read once branching program problem
equivalence
with a probabilistic machine it's just
just an interesting um algorithm that
we're going to come up with
um
so in our pro in our proof attempt where
did we use the probabilistic nature for
bpp because we're running the two
branching programs on a random input
um
i mean
so you know you have your two branching
programs you pick a random
input to run those two branching
programs and you see what they do
that's where that's why it's
probabilistic
when you're thinking about random
behavior of the machine
it's a um that's a probabilistic machine
so each branch of the machine
is going to be like the way we normally
think about non-determinism somebody's
asking whether
we think of the complexity of the
machine in terms of all of the branches
of the machine
or
um each branch separately it's we always
think about for non-deterministic
machines each branch separately
um i'm not totally sure i understand the
question there so are all the inputs
built in and we randomly choose one
through coin flips
not sure i understand that question
either we're given as input the two
branching programs
and then we flip coins you know kind of
using our non-determinism
you can think about it equivalent in
terms of coin flips to choose the values
of the variables so now we have a set of
variable
inputs to the
values of the variables
and we use that to
um as input to the branching programs to
see what whether they
to see what answers they give and we in
particular whether they give the same
answer on that randomly chosen uh input
let's move on um
all right
so now sort of moving us toward
um
the actual bpp algorithm for uh
um read once branching program
equivalence
testing um
we have to think about
a different way
to
um
we need an alternate way of thinking
about
the computation of a branching program
it's going to look very similar but it's
going to lead us in a direction that's
going to allow us to talk about this
um these non-boolean inputs that i refer
to um just kind of where we're going
we're going to be simulating branching
programs with polynomials
if that helps you sort of as an
overarching plan but we'll we'll get
there a little slowly
so okay here's a branching program
read once branching program um we're not
going to use the read once feature uh
just yet but we'll that'll come later
but anyway here's a branching program
um
and um
uh
oh here's my branch and i
put crashed here
start that again
um
okay so we take an input
um whatever it is um
and
thinking about the computation of the
branching process so we're not thinking
about the algorithm right now we're just
thinking about branching programs for
the minute we're going to get back to
the algorithm later
so the branching program follows a path
as i indicated when you have a
particular input your x1 is 0
x2 is 1
x3 is 1 so the output is going to be 1
in this case
okay
so
the way i want to think about this a
little differently
is i want to label all of the nodes and
all of the edges
uh with a value
that tells me whether or not this yellow
path went through that node or edge
it's going to be just a
doing the same but
you may think this is no difference at
all but i want to label all the all of
the things on the yellow path
i'm going to label them or the one
and all of the things that are not on
the yellow path
i'm going to label with a zero
so i'm keeping those trying to keep
those labels apart from the original
branching program
which are written in white these labels
are written yellow
but these labels have to do with the
execution of the branching program on an
input
so once i have an input that's going to
determine a one or a zero
label
for every node and edge
now
if we want to look at the output from
this branching program after we have
that labeling we only have to look at
the label of the one output node because
that's if that one has a one on it that
means that the path went through that
one and so therefore we should output
output output uh the output is one
um
uh
so
i'm going to give you another way of
assigning that instead of just coming
finding the path first and then coming
up with the labeling afterward i'm going
to give you a different way of coming up
with that labeling kind of building it
up inductively starting at the start
node and building up that labeling
you'll see what i mean
by my example
so if i have a label on this node
so i already know
whether or not the path went through
that node
you know label 1 means the path went
through it label 0 means the path
doesn't it does not go through it
[Music]
that's going to tell me how to label the
two outgoing edges
so if i'm if i've already labeled this
with a where a is a zero or one then
uh
what what expression should i use
um
to how do
under what circumstances will i label
what's what's the right label for this
one outgoing edge here
well if a is zero
that means the pair we know the path did
not go through this node so there's no
way it could go through that edge
similarly
if x i
is a zero
that means even if we did go through
that node
the path would go through the other edge
other outgoing edge and not to this one
so that tells us that the boolean
expression which describes the value the
label of this uh node in the execution
is going to be the and
of the
the value on the node and the um the
query variable of that node
now
think about what's the right way to
label the other edge
the the execution value of the other
edge
again you have to have go through this
node so a has to be one but now you want
x i to be 0 in order to go through that
edge so that means it's going to be a
and the complement of x i
okay so this is going to just tell me
this i'm writing a formula for how we're
labeling these uh these edges
based on the label of the of the parent
node
similarly if i have a bunch of edges
where i already know the values the
labels uh the execution levels there
let's say so i have a1 a2 and a3 what is
the right label to put on this node
um
well if any one of those is a one
that means the path went through that
edge and so therefore it's going to go
through that node
so that tells us that the label to put
on that node is the or
of the labels on the incoming edges
okay
questions on this
so now this is kind of setting the stage
for
starting to think about this
um
more toward polynomials instead instead
of using a boolean algebra
so um
quite i'm getting question how do we
know what the execution path is which
nodes to label we're going to be
labeling all of the nodes
so we start off with labeling the uh
did i say that here we should we start
up i didn't say but i should have we
label the the start node with one that
because the path always goes through the
start node so without even talking about
a path we just label the start node 1.
maybe we'll do an example of this also
but
now once we label this star this node 1
we have an expression
that tells us
how to label the two outgoing um the two
outgoing edges this edge and that edge
um
and i'm doing it without
knowing the values of the variables i'm
doing it kind of i'm just making an
expression uh which is going to describe
what those labels would be
once you tell me what the input
assignment is
okay so i'm just sort of it's almost
like a symbolic execution here i'm just
writing down the different expressions
for how to calculate what these things
should be
um
let's
let me um
maybe this will become clearer as we
continue
so the poll now this is the big idea of
this proof um
we're going to use something called
arithmetization
we're going to convert from thinking
about things in the boolean world to
thinking about things in the
arithmetical world where we you have
arithmetic
over integers let's say for now um
so instead of ands and ors we're going
to be talking about pluses and times
um
and uh
we're going to the way we're going to
make the bridge
is bishop by showing how to simulate the
ands and ors
the hand and or operations with the plus
and times operations
um
so um
assuming
one means true and zero means false
if you have
the expression a and b
as a boolean expression
we can represent that as a times b
using arithmetic
because
um it has it computes exactly the same
value
when we have um
the boolean
representation of true and false uh
being one and zero
so you know
one and one
is one
and one times one is one
and anything else you know one and zero
zero and one zero and zero
if you if you applied the times operator
you're going to get the same value so
times is very much like and in this
sense
okay we're going to write it as just a b
usually without the time symbol
so if we have a complement
how would we simulate that
with arithmetic
well
again
here we're just flipping one and zero
in using the complement operation that's
going to be the same as subtracting the
value from one that also flips it from
uh
between one and zero
um how about or if you have a or b
well um
it's slightly more complicated
because you use a plus b
um
but
you have to subtract off the product
because
what you want is this this
simulation should be
give you exactly the same value so what
if you have one or one
you want that to be a one a one answer
you don't want it to be a two
so you have to subtract off the product
um
uh
and the goal is is to have a faithful
simulation
of the and and or by using plus and
times so you get exactly the same
answers out
when you put in boolean values here
okay so
um
just to say where we're going
what this is going to
um
you know it sounds it's superficially we
haven't really done anything
um
this is
but um
what this is going to enable us to do is
plug in values which are not boolean
because you know it doesn't make sense
to talk about it makes sense to talk
about one and zero but it doesn't make
sense to talk about two and three
but it does talk it makes sense to talk
about two times three
and that's going to be
a useful
um okay so let's just see
um
remember
that that
that um
that inductive labeling procedure that i
described before
um where i labeled gave the execution
labels on the edges
depending upon the label of the parent
node and which node which variable is
being queried um so
if i know that this value is an a but
now the
uh
okay
so i'm just going to write this down
using uh arithmetic instead of using
boolean uh
operations
uh so before we have this was a an a and
x i if you remember from the previous
slide
um now what are we going to use instead
because we're going to use this
conversion here instead of and we're
going to use multiplication
that's just a times x i
what about on this side
here was
a and the complement of x i
now the complement of x i is one minus x
i
in the uh arithmetically so this becomes
a times one minus x i
okay um
similarly
here
we did the or
to get the label on the node from its
the labels of its incoming edges
now we're going to do something a little
strange um because we have a formula
here for or
but for technical reasons that will come
up later
this is not a convenient representation
for us
what i'm going to use instead of this
one i'm just going to simply say
just take the sum
why is that good enough
in this case this is still going to be a
faithful representation and give the
right answer all of the time
and that's because
for our
branching programs
read once or otherwise read once is not
coming in yet
for our branching programs
they're a cyclic
so they can never enter a node on two
different paths
there's at most one way to come into a
node uh um on a path through the on an
execution path through the branching
program if it comes in through uh
through to this edge
um
there's no way for it to for this edge
to also have a path because that means
you have to go out and come back
and and
have a cycle
in the branching program which is
disallowed so at most one of these edges
can have the path go through it
so at most one of these a's
can be a one the others are going to be
zero and therefore just taking the sum
is going to give us a value of either 0
or 1 but it's never going to give a
value higher and so you don't have to
subtract off these product terms
okay a little bit complicated here if
you didn't totally get that
um don't worry for now
you know we're um
you know more concerned that you get the
the big picture of what's going on
um
okay so um
i think we're almost
um
let me just see how far we are
yeah
so i'm just going to work through an
example and i think that'll bring us uh
let's just see any questions here
not seeing any
it means you're either all
totally understanding or or you're
totally lost i never can tell
um so feel free to ask a question if
you're even if you're confused um
you know i'll do my best
okay maybe this example might help
um
so now what we're going to do is using
this sort of arithmetical
view
of the way i
branching program's computation um you
know
is executed when when we're running it
uh um
you know an input through it um this is
going to allow us now to give a meaning
to running the branching program on
non-boolean inputs so maybe this example
will illustrate that
um
so let's just take this particular
branching program here
okay um
this branching program it's just on two
variables x1 and x2 and actually
computes a familiar function
this is the exclusive or function if you
look at it for a minute you'll see that
this is going to give you
x1 exclusive or x2
so it's going to be
one if either of the x1 or x2 are one
but it's going to be zero if they're
both one that's what this branching
program computes
now but let's take a
look um at running this branching
program instead of on the
usual boolean values let's run it on x1
equal to 2 and x2 equal to 3.
now
uh
um
you know a common confusion
might be that you're looking you know
when you do the x1 query you're looking
for
another
outgoing edge which is labeled two no
that's not what i'm doing what i'm doing
here is i'm somehow
uh through this execution
by assigning these other values i'm kind
of blending together the computation of
x x
uh 1 equal to 0 and x1 equal to 1
together
i don't know if that makes any sense but
let's look through the example
um so first of all these are the
labeling rules that i had from
uh the previous slide when i
used plus and times instead of and or
okay
now i'm going to show you how to use
that to label the nodes and edges of
this graph based on this input
and that'll determine an output
would be the value on the uh
the one node
okay so we always start out by labeling
the start node with one
that's just the rule
um
and
uh okay
sorry
let's let's think about it together
before i blurt out the answer
what's going to be the label on
this edge
so this is one of the outgoing edges uh
from a node that already has a label so
that's going to be this case here
and what we do is if we take we take the
label of that node
and since it's a one edge that's
outgoing
we multiply that label
by um the value
of uh that
uh
variable
of the the assignment to that variable
so x1 is two
so we take the the it's good this the a
here is one
x1 is a assigned to two so it's going to
be one times two
is going to be the value
the execution value we put on this edge
so it's going to be 2.
what's going to be the value we put on
the other edge the other edge the 0
outgoing edge from x1
so once you think about that for a
second
so now we're going to use this
expression
it's a times 1 minus x i
and so x i again is two so one minus x i
is one minus two
um
does that mean that's how complementary
but okay let's say that so it's one
minus 2 so that's minus 1 times the
label
1 here so you get minus 1 as the label
on this edge
now
keep in mind
that if i had plugged in and this is
very important if i had plugged in
boolean values here
i would be getting out the same boolean
values that you would get just by
following through the path
you know the things on the path would be
one the things off the path would be
zero
um
but uh
but with what's kind of uh what's
happening here is that
there's still a meaning
when the inputs are not boolean
so let's continue here how about what's
going to be the value on this node
so think with me i think it will help
you
so
now we're using this rule here we add up
all the values on the incoming edges
there's only one incoming edge which is
value two so that means this guy's going
to get a two and similar on this one
this guy's going to get a minus one
now let's take a look at this edge
so this is a the zero outgoing edge from
a node label two with with label x2
so this is the zero outgoing edge
the node the label is two so it's going
to be two times
one minus the x2 value x2 is 3 so 1
minus 3 is minus 2. it's going to be 2
times -2
which is minus 4.
so similarly you can get the value here
the value on the the
one outgoing edge is going to be
2 times
x the x2 value which is 3 so that's
going to be 6.
and these two here
uh um
so you know now we have a minus one
and the outgoing is a
it's a it's a zero edge so it's one
minus three
and here it's going to be one times
no
1 times 3 i'm sorry 1 times 3.
um
so you get the out the answer is minus
3. so now what's the label on the zero
output edge
so you have to add in add up the two
incoming edges here so we have
uh this
this edge here was a two
this edge coming in here is a six so
it's going to be two plus six
it's eight and what about this edge this
node here this is an important node
because this is going to be the output
so
it has
um
uh
you know minus three coming in
and a minus four coming in so you add
those together
you get a minus seven
i mean you may wonder
what
what the world is going on here um
just a lot of mumbo jumbo uh
but we're gonna make sense of all this
not today uh we're gonna have to argue
why this is
what the meaning that we're gonna get
out of this is gonna be
um but the point point is
that
this is going to lead to a new algorithm
for testing this is again getting back
to what we were
doing
this is
the equivalence problem for read once
branching programs so now what the new
algorithm is going to do is going to
pick a random non-boolean assignment
so it's going to randomly assign
values to the x's
and to some non-boolean values instead
of zeros and ones we're going to plug in
random
integer values we'll make that clear
next time what's what this what the
domain is going to be
um
[Music]
and then once we have that non-boolean
assignment we're going to value b1 and
b2
and if they disagree
out there in that extended
domain
then we have to show that they're not
equivalent and will reject
and we'll also show that
if they were equivalent
then even when we evaluate them
then we have to show that if if they're
not equivalent that they're very likely
to to have a difference in the
non-boolean uh domain and so um if they
agree it it
it gives you evidence that the two are
really equivalent
um so the completeness proof will come
after thanksgiving so with that um i'm
gonna wish you all a nice uh break um oh
we have a check in here sorry
oh yeah this is a good one
i don't know how if you're following me
uh but
um if i plug in one for x1
and y for x2
does it do the inputs in the assignment
need to be distinct no
it could be the same value
i could be
uh two and two here that's perfectly
valid
but here i'm going to plug in 1 for x1
i'm going to plug in a
variable for x2 y
and i'm going to do the whole
calculation that i just did and now
what's going to be the output
and i mean this looks like a pain to
figure out you could do it it looks like
a pain but let me give you a big hint
um
remember that this thing
is supposed to be calculating the
original branching program calculates
the exclusive or function
and that means when i plug in
um a boolean value
i should get the exclusive or value
coming out
so if i already know that x1 is one
which of these is consistent
with getting
a value
uh that the exclusive or function would
compute
so let me launch the poll on that
so we're at a time
so let's just let this run for another
10 seconds
okay
i'm going to close this
ready
um
yes indeed
a is the right answer because that's one
if i know that one variable is one then
the exclusive or
is going to be the complement of the
other variable
which is one minus y so that's what you
would get if you calculated this
um
because this is what we did today
and um
feel free to ask questions so let me
just so we're going to spend a good
chunk i'll review this
what we've done so far but then we're
going to carry it forward and spend a
good chunk of tuesday's lecture after
the
thanksgiving break uh proving that this
uh procedure that i just subscribed
worked and works and it's um
it's an interesting but somewhat
you know it's not such an easy proof uh
so we're going to spend the try to do it
slowly and clearly and then um but this
notion of arithmetization is going to be
this is this was
you know
it's it's an important notion in
complexity and so um we'll
we'll see it again coming up in another
proof afterwards
in about interactive proof systems
okay um
so please ask questions
so the output is the value of the one
output one state yes
that was a question i got
other questions
somebody's saying minus seven is not the
xor of two and three
what is the xor of two and three
so by the way i i should say we kind of
ran a little short on time i'm not
saying that we discovered some
fundamental new truth about xor here
um because that would be bizarre
it really depends on the arbitrary
decision that we made to say true is one
and false is zero
we could have come up with a different
representation for true and false and
then you would get a different value
for xor coming out of that you know from
the arithmetization that i just
described um
but uh for this particular way of
representing true and false that's how
xor and this particular branching
program that's how uh
what how xor evaluates
the the remainder of the proof so
somebody's asking which is it which is
true the fundamental theorem of algebra
which talks about polynomials and the
number of roots that you can have that's
going to be that's going to be critical
um
uh so the that is the fundamental
theorem of algebra that's where we're
going good good question
well you know so the
somebody's complaining that you know
we're not taking the
digit
binary representation of two and three
and taking the
bit by bit
um
xor well that's i'm not
you know
binary representation is not a part of
this
we're thinking of these as two elements
of a field
um of a finite field which we'll talk
about later
represent the binary representation is
isn't
is not is not entering into this
discussion
um
so talk about why just doing the sum is
enough
um
i think that was
so why is it i mean here it is why is
just doing the sum when i'm
looking at the um
the
how to describe the value of this node
based upon the values of all the
incoming nodes
and remember the point of the the
starting point of this is that we have
to faithfully represent the boolean
logic with the arithmetic
and then we're going to use that and
extend it to non-boolean values but as a
starting point we have to faithfully
represent the boolean values
now the boolean values
on the incoming edges at most one of
them can be
can be a one
because
the ones correspond to the
edges
of the execution path
and you can't make an execution path
um that's going to have two
branches
that's going to go through a node twice
because then you have a loop
and we don't have there's no cycles
allowed
okay
so i think where it's at four
um
i want to say farewell to all you all
have a great uh week and i'll see you
when you get back
you